what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so I got to tell you guys guardians of
the galaxy is an enigma to me not in the
sense of the group itself of course I
know about the group but with regards to
why Marvel would make a guardians of the
galaxy film and I thought about this I
sat and I thought about it time and time
again and I asked myself why would
Marvel make a guardians of the galaxy
film because everything that we've seen
so far
has been confined to the planet Earth
and most of the movies that we will see
that are coming up are confined to the
planet Earth the Avengers was confined
to the planet Earth Loki invading with
the Chitauri an army that was a planet
Earth event Captain America was planet
earth or had to do with as guard but he
spent a majority of his time on the
planet Earth and so everything has
revolved around the planet Earth and so
I thought well maybe Marvel is taking
you know the Marvel Cinematic Universe
to the stars maybe they're taking it to
the cosmos maybe to just show us that
there is a bigger picture here but that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
because Marvel is doing everything in
phases Marvel is doing phase 1 and phase
2 and page 3 and phase 4 and there's got
to be an end to this there has to be a
focal point there's got to be
this final storyline that Marvel is
approaching with regards to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that's what we're
going to be talking about in this video
in this video we're going to be
answering or at least attempting to
answer the question what does guardians
of the galaxy have to do with the
Infinity Gauntlet I just want to get
so what would a video about the
guardians of the galaxy be without an
explanation on the guardians of the
galaxy so we're going to sum this up
really really fast because we've got
some cool stuff to talk about in this
video
so the guardians of the galaxy that
we're going to be seeing in the upcoming
film is actually the second incarnation
of the guardians of the galaxy the first
incarnation of the guardians of the
galaxy was a comic book team that came
out in 1969 and this was about a team
that fought in the 31st century
now they fought different villains and
different characters and so on and so
forth but probably the most interesting
villain they thought was a guy named
Kovac he was like half-man half-machine
basically but he had the ability to
siphon energy from virtually any source
and there comes a point where he kind of
taps into Galactus ship and gains the
power cosmic
and as a result of gaining the power
cosmic he can do all kinds of crazy
stuff he's like Silver Surfer basically
except that unlike Silver Surfer he
could manipulate time and space when he
can time travel the guardians of the
galaxy are believed to have successfully
defeated a core vac in the 31st century
with the assistance of Thor in this
timeline but as we learn Cormac actually
travels into the past and it takes the
combined effort of the guardians of the
galaxy from the 31st century
The Avengers from the 20th century to
successfully defeat core vac and kind of
rid him of rid the universe of him once
and for good the current incarnation of
the guardians of the galaxy team is a
team that came along in 2008 and this
team came along as a response to the
annihilation conquest storyline now
we're not going to go into the
annihilation conquest storyline suffice
it to say that it is this great big huge
war that takes place between the Phalanx
and the Kree but the team forms due to
their their head guy their leader
star-lord wanting to form a team that is
equivalent to a galactic version of the
Avengers and that is basically what the
guardians of the galaxy are they are a
galactic version of the Avengers
they are a team that comes together to
face a galactic threat that no one
person can defeat on their own and
they're composed of a pretty unique
group of people of course you have
star-lord who is their leader he's a
MACT a master tactician he is a master
thinker in the realm of military
strategy but he is not super powerful in
and of himself he has a suit that grants
him you know enhanced strength enhanced
durability and so on and so forth and he
has a gun that can fire the elements of
the universe
but with regards to his physic
powers there are a lot of other people
who were stronger than him the
second-in-command to him is probably the
character that's going to steal the show
as far as the head of Bert as far as the
movie goes and this is rocket racoon and
Rocket Raccoon is the result of genetic
manipulation of course he is the basis
for him is a raccoon and he comes from
the planet called half world I think it
is where it's kind of a home for the
mentally insane more or less but the
indigenous species are the indigenous
animals of the planet were manipulated
genetically so they would have the
intelligence of a human being and they
would also retain the traits of their
respective organisms so Rocket Raccoon
has all the attributes of a raccoon that
is to say enhanced hearing enhanced
smell enhanced sight so on and so forth
but he also has bipedal movement of a
human being and he has the intelligence
of a human being in addition he's a
superb marksman he never misses his
target it doesn't mean he's going to
kill whatever it is that he shoots at
but it does mean that when he shoots at
them he will not miss of course after
that is Groot and Groot is kind of like
this tree looking thing and Groot is
really interesting because he is kind of
this prince among his own people and so
he has a technological level of genius
but is believed that because he is so
astronomically intelligent and because
we are so unintelligent relative to him
we are unable to understand exactly what
it is that he's saying and so whenever
he talks to us it sounds like all he
says is I am Groot when in reality he's
probably saying a whole host of other
things that we just simply can't
understand after him is Drax the
destroyer and Drax the destroyer is a
genetically or not really genetically
he's really kind of a created being Drax
the destroyer was originally a guy named
Arthur Douglas and Arthur Douglas was an
earthbound person but he and his family
were supposedly killed by Thanos Thanos
was invading or attempting to invade the
planet Earth we learned that Arthur
Douglass's daughter actually survives
and she is taking to Thanos's homeworld
Titan by Thanos his father mentor to be
taught and to be raised to become a
prodigious fighter Arthur Douglas
himself has a spirit taken from the
afterlife I assume and put into the body
of a newly created being and of course
this is done at the hands of both mentor
and the in-betweener
this newly created being is Drax the
destroyer and Drax the destroyer despite
having you
run-of-the-mill powers that is to say
strength speed stamina durability so on
and so forth
he has a very unique ability and this
ability grants him the power to always
locate Thanos no matter where Thanos is
in the cosmos now this is a very big
deal because this makes a Drax a
destroyer a very pivotal player in a
role where by Thanos needs to either be
tracked down or people need to be
removed from the path of Thanos and we
will see this play out later on in
Marvel Comics and our different
scenarios which we're not going to go
into that pretty much makes up the core
group now there are other people that
come in and out there's go more on
people like that but so if I sort of say
these are kind of the core members of
the the guardians of the galaxy now to
the cool stuff this is when we see
really interesting things happen because
the question becomes why is Marvel
making a movie about guardians of the
galaxy this is really comes on it kind
of comes out of left field everything
that we've seen so far is earthbound
stuff The Avengers was based on planet
Earth Captain America is based on planet
Earth Loki invaded planet Earth
Thanos was looking to conquer the planet
Earth at the end of the Avengers or at
least we assume so given that his
henchmen is talking about courting death
and so on and so forth we see a lot of
different things take place we see the
infinity gems rolling out we see the
Infinity gem that was in the staff of
Loki we see the Infinity gym that was
given to the collector at the end of
Thor 2 and the infinity gems are these
gems that represent different aspects of
the cosmos the aspect of the mind
reality time-space power the soul
different things like that and a person
who possesses infinity gem possesses
total control over whatever it is that
Infinity gym represents so the Infinity
gym of time for example a person who
possesses this gym possesses the ability
to master time and they can do anything
with regards to time they can stop it
they can travel back through it they can
travel forward through it they can slow
it down they could do any number of
things with ton so when you look at this
is really kind of like what in the world
is going on here you know what's what's
happening here and then I started
thinking about it because I spent all
day really kind of asking myself this
question I said okay let's let's sit
down Rob let's sit down and let's think
about this let's ask this question why
are the guardians of the galaxy being
featured here and then I answered myself
this guardians of the galaxy film I
think will be a filler film this will be
a film that will do nothing more than
introduce elements that will become
important later on down the line it's
like learning chemistry you learn the
first steps of chemistry and those build
on other steps and those build on other
steps and ultimately you end up taking a
final exam on everything that you've
learned with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it appears to be the same way
with this movie this movie's main
villain is a guy called Ronan the
accuser
now running the accuser is a member of a
race called the Kree now the fact that
he's part of the Kree isn't important
what is important is the race the Kree
because this can possibly introduce us
to another character that is very very
important to future timelines and future
stories that take place in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the reason why I
say this is important is because I think
at this point there's become obvious
that Marvel is really kind of discarded
the chronological order of things and so
if we're talking about an Infinity
Gauntlet storyline the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline came out chronologically in
1990 18 years after our introductory for
our introduction to the guardians of the
galaxy so this is the case then Marvel
might be looking towards future events
and one of these events hails around
another member of the Kree aside from
running the accuser and this guy is
Captain Marvel now Captain Marvel is of
course a member of the Curia and as a
member of the Kree he possesses the same
kind of powers that members of the Kree
possess but he also has abilities that
are far beyond that what those abilities
are don't really matter for this
discussion what does matter is that
later on in the Marvel Comics they have
a story line called the Thanos
imperative and the Thanos imperative is
a storyline whereby a future version of
a character named Adam warlock that we
have not been introduced to yet ends up
going insane due to his manipulation of
the soulja the soul infinity gym in
addition to some manipulation by the
in-betweener as a result he is totally
nuts and he leads a group called the
universal Church of Truth now after the
events of the annihilation conquest
storyline that we had previously
mentioned the result was a rift a tear
in the universe now what was on the
other side of this tear we didn't know
all we knew was that this tear existed
and there had been various groups and
entities that hadn't tasked with
guarding this rift to ensure that
nothing went through it and not
thing came through it our direction but
what is up happening is the Magus who is
this version of Adam warlock that's gone
insane shows up at this rift and also
teleports a multitude of planets that
are composed of people who are faithful
to the universal Church of truth and
detonates all the planets and tears the
rift open what comes through this rift
is the contents of an alternate universe
where by the entity death does not exist
and therefore no one can die and so life
has evolved to extreme degrees you have
all kinds of crazy creatures that exist
between universes that now exist in that
universe you have characters like
Captain America and Iron Man and
different people like that who have not
died and they have just kind of become
inherently evil human beings to our
perspective and they they instead of
forming a group called The Avengers they
now form a group called the revenger z'
but in any event besides all that we're
getting kind of off topic here what ends
up happening is Santos has taken to meet
with the this universes version or I
guess to combat this universes version
of Captain Marvel who simply just known
as Marvel and Thanos immediately gives
up the fight the result is kind of a
ruse it is a trick the entity death from
our universe takes Marvel away and as a
result a chain reaction occurs meaning
that everybody in his universe that
hails from is universal is currently in
our universe ends up dying and his
universe ceases to exist
now this storyline is unimportant for
the most part suffice it to say that it
could be the possible storyline they
might have n guardians of the galaxy -
but what is important is that it
introduces us to major characters that
have huge rules later on if they choose
to go this route and including the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline after this
storyline takes place it introduces us
to the Magus and introduces us to Adam
warlock and introduces us to the entity
death which Thanos has an affection with
and which Stannis will do virtually
anything to gain her affections
including wiping out half the life in
the sense he hid universe when he
possesses the Infinity Gauntlet and it
also introduces us to other incarnations
of Marvel characters which is always
kind of cool to see
so if Marvel chooses to go this route if
Marvel chooses to take this road and to
head towards this direction then I think
the ultimate
really kind of makes sense and it will
really kind of pull people in and draw
people into something interesting now as
far as you Infinity Gauntlet storyline
itself that's a discussion we'll have in
another video but suffice it to say the
inclusion of guardians of the galaxy in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is a huge
deal that cannot be understated because
there are so many interesting things
that we're going to be able to see take
place as a result of their involvement
now it could just be this is a one-shot
and don't have guardians of the galaxy
and we'll never see or hear from them
again but because of the fact that
Marvel is doing phases I'm very inclined
to believe that not only will we see
this team again but this team's
involvement is going to have major
ramifications it's also possible that
they got into the galaxy will be just
one of the teams that fights against
Thanos when he captures the Infinity
Gauntlet that could very well be the
case in which case all of this is no
limbo but it is fun to speculate so with
that being said I'm gonna bring this
video to an end hope you guys enjoyed it
if you did and if you're not super
confused let me know and that will catch
you guys later peace